okay happy times let's have a look at
this guy right now this particular area
is interesting and there are two ways
that we can approach it and they kind of
equally thought that I will show you
okay have a look again just like before
the one thing I'm missing from the
diagram is the actual area that we're
young that we're supposed to be
calculated where is the actual okay
there's two cards on it so first there's
this valley bitter you're talking about
- yeah it's fine okay got that one there
what is another area that yeah it's the
mobile okay sorry
it's cozy area so you've got you've got
these two slices again I'm going to name
them right so we call this a one and
this one age and how do I work out this
area so yes yes okay so you can see
you've got one two three four things
than our boundaries right so there's the
graph then there's this horizontal line
and then this put axes oh fourth
axes so if I say to you okay I have one
two three and where should I put this
one I'll put it over here four lines
right and I said so many areas that up
bounded by this full Alliance okay you
can see this area over here has nothing
to do with that last line that I drew
but it's still bounded right it's still
a closed area that I can talk about okay
so the same way even though a one has
nothing to do with that why it was mine
why good pickup it's still bounded by
this guy and the cordon axis the X of
the one okay in exactly the same way
that a tune has nothing to do with the x
axis but it's still included within the
boundaries that are interested in
right so having just made a mess of my
working space how do I work out these
areas eight ones pretty easy
okay any one is pretty straightforward
you do need to know some boundaries
don't you it's not too hard to work out
what the x-intercept is though it's it's
negative one okay cuz all you have to
solve this for y equals zero you get X
cubed is negative one
excellent what so it's not hard to work
out a one right off the bat integral
from negative one to zero okay here's my
function X cubed plus 1 with respect to
X DX integrand
up to the primitive function which gives
me X to the 4 on 4 plus X from negative
1 to 0 ok I'll evaluate it at the upper
bound which is 0 that gives you sure and
then I'll evaluate at my lower bound
which gives me that's 1/4 minus 1 that
looks like three quarters to me you
happy with that
ok great area one is fun area 2/3 you
have to be a little more careful with ok
now I've been talking a lot about this
DX thing right and where it came from
it started from that just like the two
horizontal with but we saw it meant more
than that right it also Ament with
respect to X like that's the variable
I'm looking
it also means in this case it binds us
to the x-axis right it's the area
underneath here but bound to this x-axis
so if I integrated for instance if I
were to integrate from north - what's
the x value that corresponds to that
I've got it's going to be 2 because 2
cubed plus 1 is like if I come from not
- and i integrate x squared plus 1 with
respect to X I'm not gonna get a 2
what am I going to get
yeah the other part right I'm gonna get
this guy I'll just put it in pants
this guy down here that's not what I
want that's money too but it's not hard
to go from that guy to get a to what is
the difference between them
yeah very good I have this rectangle
here right I know what its width is I
know what its height is so therefore a 2
is the difference between versions I
would say a 2 is 9 top sides of that 9
million times to take away that integral
we got to talk about that we'll talk
about that in a minute
thank you spoilers ok this is this is me
considering the way I would normally
approach it which is with respect to X I
do have a function in terms of X so
might as well all right now I've got 18
I've already worked out what the period
function is which is nice so I've got X
to the 4 on 4 plus X from Norton to 18
take away all right I'll evaluate at my
upper bound first which is with 16 or
for witches or plus to take away 0 yeah
happy times that's 6 so this is 12 yeah
yes and I'll show you a minute so just
before I finished that that's it right
the total area is the sum of those let's
see qa1
yeah it does
12 and 3/4 units square the cage